It's easy to imagine a world
without labor unions.
We're essentially living
in that world now.
And we are worse off as a result.
Few of you probably belong to unions,
but almost all of you benefit from them.
It was unions that brought us the weekend.
More importantly,
unions built the middle class
by ensuring that workers
had the incomes to support families,
to buy homes and cars,
and to dream that their children
could do better than they could.
It was union power and advocacy
that helped us win Social Security
and health insurance
upon which almost all of us depend.
In the 1950s,
33 percent of private-sector workers
belonged to unions.
Big labor stood proudly
beside big business and big government.
No more.
Today, only six percent
of private sector workers
are members of unions.
With their decline in numbers came
a decline in political and economic power.
And the result?
A significant increase in inequality.
A significant deterioration
in the possibility of a middle life --
A middle class lifestyle
for this generation or the next.
And a receding chance to own
a home or afford retirement.
We need unions to regain the power
so that we can regain what we have lost,
build a better future
and help forge democracies
that are built on a decent social contract
between citizens and government
and among citizens themselves.
Yes, we need unions today as much as ever.
As a professor of political science,
and someone who has studied
labor unions for a long time,
I can tell you that one of the most
important things that unions do
is to counterbalance
the power of corporations.
They even the playing field.
Yes, we need unions.
But we need better and different unions
that are more attuned to the 21st century.
Let's picture the world before unions.
Small children toiling all day
and even into the night
in noisy, polluted factories.
Or immigrant women workers
jumping from a burning sweatshop
because the fire escapes were locked
so that they could not take breaks.
That was New York City in 1911,
that's Bangladesh now.
But unions changed that
by winning protections for workers.
They transformed lives.
They enabled even the worst off
to achieve the American dream.
Consider the longshore workers,
those who load and unload ships.
In the morning,
the boss came and yelled
all along the shore --
thus the name longshore.
They pleaded for the scarce jobs,
just as migrant day laborers do today
at places like Lowe's and Home Depot.
It was humiliating, degrading.
But when the unions won the right
to organize and won contracts,
the wharf rats became lords of the dock.
They became middle class.
They could marry.
They could support families,
they could send their children to college,
they had health insurance and benefits.
They had dignity, respect.
They were full American citizens.
Unions enabled others
to attain the American dream
by raising wages generally
and by reducing wage disparities
between men and women
and among the races.
My research has shown me
that with every transformation
in the economy, the technology,
the way we work,
there has been an evolution
in the labor movement.
Craft unions,
think construction work
or even beer making,
emerged from medieval guilds.
With the rise of industry --
auto, steel --
new forms of organization emerged.
When white collar workers in offices,
in government, in health care
in professions,
won voice and representation,
yet another kind of union developed.
In my mind, in my ears,
is Dolly Parton singing "9 to 5",
inspired by a real-life
union of that name.
When you hear that song,
thank the unions for a decent working day.
History shows
that unions helped people
get dignity, rise out of poverty,
inhibit workplace dangers and harassment
and improve health
and well-being of us all.
These are not yesterday's problems.
Workers of today
still need and want unions.
An MIT survey revealed that 50 percent
of the non-union workforce
would join a union if given a chance.
So, Margaret,
if unions are so great,
why are they in such serious decline?
Because the odds are stacked against them.
Many of you have read
about the Amazon warehouse workers
who failed to win a union
representation election in Alabama.
They failed because of concerted
employer opposition.
Indeed, there are many
employers and politicians
who are preventing
the reform of labor laws
passed nearly a century ago in another era
and another economy.
These are laws
that inhibit agriculture and domestic
workers from organizing,
largely Black and brown workers.
They make it hard for workers
in the gig economy to organize,
those we call forth with our apps:
rideshare, delivery service,
specialized tasks.
There are employers and politicians
who are pushing states
to pass “right-to-work” laws:
laws that abolish the requirement
that those who are covered by union
contracts have to pay union dues.
This effectively kills the unions.
Many workers in 27 states
do not have to pay for the benefits
the unions provide for them.
States that include Michigan,
Indiana and Wisconsin,
former union strongholds.
And society loses big.
A recent study revealed
that in right-to-work law states,
there is slower economic growth,
higher consumer debt, lower wages,
worse health outcomes
and lower civic participation
than in states without such
laws on the books.
But it's not just employers
and politicians
that are holding unions back.
Unions are a cause
of some of their own problems.
Some unions are extremely bureaucratic,
stifling debate and innovation.
Some union leaders are corrupt.
Rigging elections, paying themselves
humongous salaries,
even when they represent
very low-income workers.
And some commit felonies.
Jimmy Hoffa is the notorious example
of a labor leader who went to prison.
But just this year,
several high-ranking officials
in the United Auto Workers
were sentenced for embezzlement.
Now, many critics, possibly some of you,
blame unions for inflation.
When wages go up, consumer prices go up.
True enough,
but so does the standard
of living for workers.
And we as taxpayers benefit
from higher standards
of living by workers.
The pandemic gave us
the term "essential workers."
If those in grocery, warehousing,
food processing, delivery,
had strong unions,
indeed any unions at all,
there would have been no need
for federal programs
for those who have jobs to feed
their families and prevent evictions.
Now there are many reasons
for union decline,
including structural ones.
The decline in union jobs
in manufacturing.
But a major reason
is public lack of awareness,
even misinformation
about the value of unions.
Well before President Reagan
fired the striking
air controllers in 1981,
there has been concerted and continuous
opposition by employers and politicians
to undermine unions.
Employers no longer suppress unions
by hiring private armies,
like US Steel, Ford
and the coal companies did.
Now they hire very high-priced
consulting firms to do that work.
Elected officials may no longer
call out the police
and the National Guard
to cart labor organizers off to jail.
Now they pass legislation that restricts
union organizing and power.
But workers are beginning to fight back
as the headlines reveal.
They are building solidarity
across racial, ethnic,
religious, partisan divides.
Martin Luther King [Jr.] exhorted us
to enwrap ourselves
in a single garment of destiny.
I have observed several unions
that I've studied
build expanded and inclusive
communities of fate
in which large numbers of others recognize
that their destinies are entwined
despite differences and distances.
This doesn't always happen,
but it can and it must.
If you took my class,
or gave me another hour,
I could give you numerous examples.
We need as employees and citizens
to build solidarity
through communities of fate
that crosses geographies and differences.
But to do that, we need to reimagine
labor unions for now.
The labor movement must evolve
as it has in the past,
even producing possibly alt unions,
alternatives to unions.
Alternatives to traditional unions.
Workers in gig professions, tech,
don't necessarily want
a traditional union,
but they do want influence
over their wages,
working conditions
and even the policies of their companies.
And they are reimagining old approaches
and coming up with new ones
in order to build worker voice and power.
Some are reconfiguring
worker cooperatives:
employee-owned businesses,
in which the workers determine wages,
working conditions
and distribution of profits.
This is not a pipe dream.
Mondragon in Spain
has over 80,000 employee owners,
takes in over 13 billion dollars a year
and redistributes its profits
to build worker skills and capacities
among its member cooperatives.
A newer approach is to use
platform technologies
to teach workers their rights.
In our global, hyperconnected
and socially isolating world,
platforms such as coworker.org or Unit
recognize and address the fact
that there is a mobile workforce
that no longer has
water coolers or lunch rooms
around which to gather and strategize.
These platforms provide workers
with a way to share experiences,
access organizing resources
and build networks at scale
across geographies and employers.
Coworker.org had a huge win with Alphabet,
the parent company of Google,
a giant among tech firms.
Alphabet workers recognize
that they are part of a community of fate
that crosses large distances.
They have been protesting
Google's contracts with the Pentagon
and with immigration authorities.
They have normal run-of-the-mill
economic union demands,
but they also have the political demand
that they should have a say
over company policies
that affect them and us.
Now, whatever you thought
of unions in the past,
I hope --
I hope that these examples
have revealed to you
what they can be today and for tomorrow.
Unions once significantly reduced
income inequality,
the gap between the rich and the poor.
They can again.
These graph lines came together
when unions rose.
I'd like to see those lines
permanently converge
and inequality reduced once and for all.
Billionaires are building
rockets to explore outer space.
This is so exciting,
but equally exciting
are the workers who are providing
the goods and services
on which those billionaires
[and] we all depend,
exploring new ways
to gain power and voice.
If even some of these
explorations succeed,
workers will gain dignity,
economic security
and the power to challenge
employers and politicians.
The result?
The resuscitation of the middle class
and a far more equitable society.
Thank you.
(Applause)